und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und marietta slomka
hüttenabend 560 millionen
das ist die hausnummer die jetzt im raum
steht so viel geld verlangen die
mautbetreiber als schadenersatz 560
millionen ist sind schon minister wegen
geringeren zurückgetreten
denn eins ist auch klar die
betreibergesellschaften könnten solche
ansprüche nicht formulieren weil es
keinen vertrag mit ihnen gegeben hätte
und den hatte verkehrsminister scheuer
unterschrieben bevor klar war ob die
maut europarechtlich überhaupt
eingeführt werden darf darf sie nicht
inzwischen weiß ursprünglich war die pkw
maut ja mal als bayerischer
wahlkampfschlager konzipiert mit denen
die csu ihren berliner
koalitionspartnern schwer auf die nerven
ging
nun könnte die ganze sache alle der
teuersten polit flops werden aus berlin
bernd benthin der minister wählt die
vorwärtsverteidigung die zahl steht kaum
im raum da hat er schon dagegen
getwittert und erklärt die forderungen
für nichtig das
bundesverkehrsministerium weist mit
aller entschiedenheit die forderungen
der firmen eventim und caps zurück sie
sind falsch
die betreiber haben keinen anspruch auf
entschädigung der bund hat die verträge
aus mehreren triftigen gründen gekündigt
im sommer kippt der europäische
gerichtshof die geplante pkw-maut
andreas scheuer hatte da schon einen
teuren vertrag unterschrieben mit
eventim in bremen und kapsch in wien die
fordern jetzt 560 millionen euro
aufwandsentschädigung und schadensersatz
jetzt haben wir es schwarz auf weiß herr
minister scheuer hat zu lasten der
steuerzahler gezockt er hat über eine
halbe milliarde euro steuergelder
riskiert nur um im wahlkampf in bayern
noch eine positive botschaft absetzen zu
können aus sicht der csu die pkw-maut
das war 2013 das prestige-projekt der
csu die pkw maut steht ebenfalls
daran aber hatte brüssel zweifel das
vorhaben landet vor dem europäischen
gerichtshof
wir müssen sie zahlen für den fall dass
es schief geht wenn vor dem ogh die
österreichische klage durchgeht ich bin
sehr entspannt
wenig später kommt das maut aussteuer
kündigt den firmen am tag nach dem
gerichtsurteil die firmen aber pochen
auf die geleistete unterschrift und
erheben ansprüche wieder
vorwärtsverteidigung scheuer stellt die
maut akten ins netz
das sind die verträge zur pkw maut
damit ist klar wir stehen bei allen
fragen zur pkw maut für maximal mögliche
transparenz
seit heute also steht eine konkrete
summe im raum über eine halbe milliarde
euro könnte den steuerzahler die
verpatzte pkw-maut kosten wenn sich
herausstellt dass 500 millionen euro
oder mehr gezahlt werden müssen wird
herr schwer sich im amt halten können
der druck innerhalb der koalition ist
heute sehr viel größer geworden
auch herr söder wird jetzt ein
fragezeichen machen müssen die bisherige
verteidigungsstrategie von herrn steuer
ist in sich zusammengebrochen
und ich gehe davon aus dass es ihm heute
noch schwerer fallen wird mit diesen
zahlen die auf dem tisch liegen sie
schon mal zu halten
mitte januar soll ein schiedsverfahren
anlaufen zwischen bund und betreibern
etwa zur gleichen zeit tag doch wieder
der untersuchungsausschuss der sich mit
scheuer smart management beschäftigt
theo koll wie eng wird es denn jetzt für
den minister
nun wenn man auf andere große politische
potenzielle fehler entscheidungen
zurückschaut dann muss selbst dieses 560
millionen euro debakel nicht unbedingt
als politisches aus bedeuten erster
haben untersuchungsausschüsse ja oftmals
auch in der vergangenheit am ende wenig
gebracht kaum ein politiker stürzt über
einen solchen untersuchungsausschuss und
politisch hat ihm gerade erst die
kanzlerin gute arbeit bescheinigt und
sein csu vorsitzender stützt ihn
weiterhin was politisch ja auch nicht
wirklich erstaunlich ist denn das ganze
thema ist von anfang an eine mit der csu
verbundene geschichte erfunden als
wahlkampfschlager ausländer maut und
immerhin haben dann bundestag und
bundesrat diese maut ja auch
verabschiedet hat die verträge am ende
übereilt unterschrieben bevor
rechtssicherheit her stimmt also wenn
süder scheuer jetzt fallen ließe dann
müsste das eigentlich auch für seehofer
und dobrindt gelten und das wiederum
könnte der größte schutz für den
verkehrsminister sein
der potenzielle schaden ist jedenfalls
enorm 560 millionen euro bleibt das am
steuerzahler hängen so könnte es
durchaus am ende kommen es droht jetzt
ein langwieriges schiedsverfahren den
prozess dazu hat shire heute eingeleitet
er selbst weist die forderung der firmen
jahr zurück aber um ehrlich zu sein das
preisschild von 560 millionen euro im
zweifel jahr zu zahlen vom steuerzahler
das hängt ab sofort und bis auf weiteres
um seinen politischen holz dankeschön
nach berlin
theo koll es sind leise praktisch
lautlose angriffe die deshalb aber nicht
weniger aggressiv und gefährlich sind
anderthalb tage lang war jetzt die
gesamte verwaltung der stadt frankfurt
betroffen
sämtliche ämter offline nichts ging mehr
wer heute zum amt wollte etwa um sich
umzumelden oder einen neuen pass zu
beantragen stand vor verschlossenen
türen
eine ganze großstadt betroffen ist ist
das natürlich spektakulär tatsächlich
geschehen solche angriffe aber ständig
bei unternehmen behörden oder
hochschulen die universität gießen etwa
ist schon seit zehn tagen nicht mehr
online
vermutet wird ein hacker-angriff ob auch
die stadt frankfurt gezielt angegriffen
wurde ist noch unklar vielleicht war sie
auch ein zufallsopfer
so oder so wird einem hier einmal mehr
bewusst wie verletzlich unsere digitale
welt ist niklas meister berichtet die
computer in der bibliothek
heruntergefahren digitale recherche
nicht möglich das internet gekappt nach
einem hacker angriff vor mehr als einer
woche sind 28.000 studierende und über
5.000 mitarbeiter an der universität
gießen noch immer offline bücher können
sie inzwischen wieder ausleihen vermerk
auf zetteln weil man irgendwie gerade
dabei seine examensarbeit zu schreiben
und auf einmal keinen zugriff mehr auf
interne ressourcen hat also ebooks und
so weiter ist das schon schwierig
ja natürlich es ist schon erschreckend
aber ich glaube ich jeder größere
institution muss sich darauf vorbereiten
und sich eben diesem risiko bewusst sein
dass so ein angriff natürlich möglich
ist auch die stadt frankfurt hat nach
einem mutmaßlichen cyberangriff heute
ihre computer vom netz genommen
die bürgerbüros geschlossen nachdem eine
e mail mit schad-software an einen
mitarbeiter geschickt wurde konnten
reagieren konnten diesen rechner vom
netz nehmen und nach derzeitiger
erkenntnis ist auch kein schaden
entstanden da wir aber davon ausgehen
müssen dass diese infizierte e mail auch
an andere empfänger versandt worden ist
haben wir vorsichtshalber alle systeme
der stadt frankfurt heruntergefahren bei
dem virus handelt es sich in beiden
fällen wohl um den trojaner e moped er
ist in einer e-mail versteckt der
empfänger wird aufgefordert einen anhang
zu öffnen und makros also bestimmte
programme zu aktivieren
wer das tut infiziert seinen rechner die
angreifer können so kontrolle über das
system bekommen
im moment ist so gefährlich weil es ein
programm ist was sich quasi automatisch
weiterverbreitet und damit ein sehr
hohen verbreitungsgrad hat und dadurch
weitere schadprogramme auf ihrem pc nach
oben geladen werden können entweder
wollen die angreifer daten abgreifen
oder sie sperren ganze rechner verlangen
lösegeld für die freigabe der digital
verband bitkom schätzt den jährlichen
schaden durch cyberkriminalität in
deutschland auf 100 milliarden euro
eine massive bedrohung für unternehmen
und behörden es gibt experten in
deutschland dazu aber es gibt nicht
genug davon ja also wir sind glaube ich
eigentlich ganz gut aufgestellt im
bereich it-sicherheit selber sicherheit
in deutschland in der deutschen
wirtschaft aber einfach mit der
zunehmende digitalisierung die anzahl
der leute die sich der oscar reicht bei
weitem nicht aus an der universität
gießen könnte es noch wochen dauern bis
die systeme wieder laufen die forschung
immerhin läuft wieder doch einen
notfallplan hatten sie nicht in der
schublade
wir werden also in dem sinne auch
sozusagen unsere verteidigung besser
strukturieren müssen
andererseits müssen wir auch bedenken
universitäten leben von der vielfalt und
der tat vom austausch also wir müssen
eine balance finden zwischen der sorge
um die sicherheit und einerseits der
gewährung von freiheiten die nötig sind
damit wir wirklich auch forschen lehren
können die studenten müssen nun alle
ihre zugangsdaten für die computer
erneuern in frankfurt immerhin laufen am
abend die systeme wieder um gießen
dagegen sieht man was ein cyberangriff
anrichten kann
weitere informationen zu
hacker-angriffen und den
sicherheitslücken in unserer
digitalisierten welt finden sie online
auf heute.de
der fall des cdu-politikers möhre das
wirft eine ganze reihe fragen auf etwa
warum ein junger mann mit neonazi
kontakten vor einem jahr überhaupt in
die cdu eintrat hätte es da nicht
alternativen gegeben
möglich dass er seine politische
gesinnung gründlich geändert hatte und
bei den christdemokraten eine heimat
suchte dazu passt aber nicht so ganz gut
dass neben neo nazi vergangenheit und
nazi täter auch noch eine mitgliedschaft
in einem dubiosen verein steht aus dem
er erst jetzt austrat insofern stellt
sich schon die frage ob die cdu in
sachsen anhalt von rechts unterwandert
werden sollte die partei tut sich mit
der angelegenheit schwer cdu chefin
annegret kramp karrenbauer sagte heute
bei einem vertrauensbruch müssten
konsequenzen gezogen werden
derweil ist in magdeburg hier nicht nur
um ein einzelnes cdu-mitglied geht
sondern um eine ganze koalition
annegret oster berichtet heute abend in
magdeburg ein angespannter
landesparteichef auf dem weg zur
krisenberatung mit den kreisvorsitzenden
wo verläuft die trennlinie der sachsen
anhalt partei zum rechten rand die
diskussion darüber hat die kenia
koalition in eine regierungskrise
gestürzt wieder einmal mehr bewusst am
körper oder in der kleidung äußere
erkennungszeichen trägt die auf eine
rechtsextreme oder antisemitische
gesinnung oder haltung schließen lassen
abzeichen aufnäher tätowierung kann
nicht mitglied der cdu sachs anders sein
das zielt auf ihn robert möritz cdu
kommunalpolitiker
vergangene woche wurde bekannt 2011 war
moritz als ordner bei einer neonazi-demo
dabei sein tattoo die schwarze sonne
besteht aus drei übereinander gelegten
hakenkreuzen bis ende letzter woche war
er mitglied beim verein unity der unter
rechtsextremismus verdacht steht trotz
alledem sein kreisverband
anhalt-bitterfeld erteilte möritz
absolution einstimmig er habe sich von
der szene glaubwürdig distanziert
seitdem kocht es in der kieler koalition
wärme situation in der herr moritz
weiterhin mitglied und funktionär eines
cdu kreisverbandes ist obwohl er am
ellenbogen eine dreifache hakenkreuz
tätowierung trägt ich frage mich immer
wie wäre das eigentlich vor zehn jahren
gewesen hätten wir der ernsthaft
diskutiert ob hakenkreuz selber in einer
demokratischen partei zu suchen haben
wie in einem brennglas zeigt der
einzelfall möritz das zentrale problem
der cdu die partei ist tief zerrissen
und der rechte flügel liebäugelt viel
eher mit der afg als mit den eigenen
koalitionspartnern
soweit ist das ein korsett was die cdu
insgesamt in eine schwierige situation
bringt die cdu steht unter druck sie
steht unter druck von rechts wo sich vor
augen führen dass die afd in
sachsen-anhalt ja fast 25 prozent der
wählerstimmen bei der letzten
landtagswahl erreicht hat für geschätzt
mindestens ein drittel der cdu in
sachsen-anhalt tendiert zumindest
richtung rechts und da flirtet man immer
wieder mit der afg 2017 stimmen cdu
abgeordnete zusammen mit den
rechtspopulisten für eine
enquetekommission gegen linksextremismus
und letzten sommer denken zwei
stellvertretende
cdu-fraktionsvorsitzende in einer
denkschrift sogar offen über eine
mögliche koalition mit der afg nach man
müsste das soziale wieder mit dem
nationalen versöhnen des rechten flügels
wagen sich in letzter zeit zunehmend aus
der deckung das in art von auflockerung
erscheinung nach rechts die dort
sichtbar werden damit werden signale
nach rechts zur afg aber auch zur
wählerschaft der ard gesendet
ausgang offen auch für robert müritz ist
der ausgang offen
mit dem beschluss positioniert sich die
cdu klar bis kommende woche muss mit
seiner aktivitäten in der
rechtsextremistischen szene offenlegen
bis dahin soll er sein amt ruhen lassen
dann will der landesvorstand entscheiden
ob es ein parteiausschlussverfahren
geben wird gegen den mann der
hakenkreuze auf seinen arm tätowiert hat
im stadtzentrum von moskau gab es eine
tödliche schießerei mit möglicherweise
politischen oder terroristischen
hintergrund damit beginnt die
nachrichten von grunde lag auf ein noch
unbekannter angreifer hat vor der
russischen geheimdienstzentrale in
moskau mit einer kalaschnikow um sich
geschossen und dabei einen mitarbeiter
des fsb getötet fünf weitere menschen
wurden verletzt
der fsb spricht von einem terroranschlag
der täter sei von sicherheitskräften
getötet worden
die ermittlungen laufen präsident putin
hatte kurz zuvor erklärt dass in diesem
jahr 33 terroranschläge in russland
verhindert worden sein
russland wird auf die us-sanktionen
gegen die ostseepipeline nord stream 2
mit gegenmaßnahmen reagieren
präsident putin erklärte auf seiner
jahrespressekonferenz wörtlich moskau
antwortet spiegel genau
zugleich erneuerte er seine zusage
weiter dass auch durch die ukraine in
die eu zu leiten
darüber haben russland und die ukraine
gerade eben in berlin eine
grundsatzeinigung erzielt unter
vermittlung der eu kommission und
deutschland
us-präsident trump muss sich einem
amtsenthebungsverfahren stellen das hat
das us repräsentantenhaus beschlossen
mit der mehrheit der demokraten stimmten
die abgeordneten für beide anklagepunkte
in der ukraine affäre machtmissbrauch
und behinderung des kongresses trump
nannte das verfahren eine schande
betonte aber zugleich dass er sich keine
sorgen machen
das eigentliche verfahren gegen ihn
findet im senat statt dort haben trumps
republikaner die mehrheit in der
slowakei hat der prozess um den mord an
dem journalisten jan kozak begonnen
angeklagt ist der geschäftsmann
katschner zu dessen mutmaßlichen
verbindungen zur italienischen mafia der
journalist recherchiert hatte der
geschäftsmann soll den mord in auftrag
gegeben haben nachdem er zuvor versucht
haben soll
kojak zu erpressen um weitere
enthüllungen zu verhindern
jan kozak und seine verlobte waren im
februar 2018 erschossen worden
eine tat die über die slowakei hinaus
erschütterte die britische königin
elizabeth ii zweiter hat das parlament
in london zum zweiten mal innerhalb von
zwei monaten wieder eröffnet die
93-jährige verlas im oberhaus die
regierungserklärung von premier johnson
der austritt aus der eu ende januar habe
höchste priorität für die regierung
außerdem kündigte sie mal
diese investitionen von knapp 40
milliarden euro umgerechnet in das
staatliche gesundheitswesen an
in berlin hat der koalitionsausschuss
erstmals mit der neuen spd parteispitze
getagt nach dem spd parteitag ging es
bei diesen ersten gesprächen mit saskia
esken und norbert walter borjans um ein
erstes offizielles kennenlernen mit
ihren amtskollegen von cdu und csu
in lockerer atmosphäre habe man auch
über mögliche gemeinsame themen im neuen
jahr beraten
der jüdische gemeinde berlin findet am
ende eines bitteren jahres statt
der anschlag eines rechtsextremisten auf
die synagoge in halle steckt allem noch
in den gliedern
mindestens so schlimm ist der zu
beobachtende antisemitismus im alltag
nicht dass das ein neues phänomen wäre
aber die schamlosigkeit und
aggressivität mit der antisemitismus
heute wieder offenbart wird hat
erheblich zugenommen
die rechte das wird man ja wohl noch
sagen dürfen rhetorik zeigt auch hier
wirkung
hinzu kommt der aus muslimischen ländern
eingewanderter judenhass besonders
bestürzend sind berichte wie häufig ist
hierzulande an schulen antisemitische
vorfälle gibt bis hin zu übelste hetze
unter jugendlichen
brigitte sauer und jutta sonne wald
berichten umso größer der jude desto
wärmer die bude solche
menschenverachtenden witze über juden
und antisemitische hetze kursierten in
einem whatsapp klassen chat am münchner
luisen gymnasium über monate hinweg
die schulleitung hat inzwischen anzeige
erstattet wie sich uns gegenüber dazu
aber nicht äußern
das städtische bildungs referat fordert
umgehend aufklärung und transparenz dass
sie das rückgrat haben und es öffentlich
machen und mit denjenigen die das ins
netz stellen in ein jet stellen sprechen
und sagen so kann es nicht sein was
machst du da genauso ist es am gymnasium
grafing geschehen
schüler einer neunten klasse schlugen
alarm als mitschüler brutale nazi lieder
und parolen auf whatsapp gepostet hatten
für den direktor stand sofort fest hier
handelt es sich um volksverhetzung
es reicht wenn ich ihnen sagt dass von
knüppel dickem blut fließen in wunden
messer der juden hinein gestoßen werden
soll
also wenn solche dinge vorkommen ist es
sofort klar da ist jeder gute geschmack
und anstand verloren
die schulleitung hat sofort die polizei
eingeschaltet und disziplinarverfahren
gegen die verantwortlichen schüler
eingeleitet für die mitschüler ist der
vorfall besonders bitter schließlich
wurde ihr gymnasium schon vor jahren für
sein engagement gegen rassismus
ausgezeichnet und war überrascht ich war
geschockt ich hätte das jetzt nicht
erwartet dass irgendwelche neuen klasse
hier sowas reinschreiben das finde ich
halt krass aber ich glaube es liegt
daran dass man durch diese dass das man
einfach so schnell was schicken kann in
den chat dass diese hemmschwelle solche
sachen zwischen zu schicken und immer
extremere sachen zu schicken
immer kleiner wird alexandra kurth von
der uni gießen weiß solche vorfälle gibt
es bundesweit an allen schultypen die
bekannten fälle wertet sie aus
gesamtzahlen hat sie nicht denn es gibt
keine einheitliche meldepflicht die aber
wäre dringend nötig erst wenn wir wissen
welches ausmaß das problem hat können
wir ja tatsächlich systematisch in der
politischen bildung in der pädagogischen
ausbildung sozusagen maßnahmen treffen
um dem entschieden entgegenzuwirken
der antisemitismus an schulen nimmt zu
und hat viele gesichter
hakenkreuzschmierereien mobbing gegen
jüdische schüler und immer wieder der
begriff du jude als schimpfwort
also hier erwarte ich eine notwendige
entsprechende fortbildung es geht nicht
über das thema sondern allein wie habe
ich zu handeln wie habe ich zu regieren
für lehrer in der ausbildung aber auch
für lehrer die unter umständen schon
viele jahre im beruf sind in grafing
wollen sie nun fächer übergreifend mehr
über antisemitismus sprechen ebenso über
den umgang mit sozialen medien
denn es ist wirklich wichtig dass man
wenn man so etwas erkennt aufsteht und
sagt ja es ist so etwas vorgefallen ist
es dort und dort passiert und wir
möchten etwas gegen unternehmen
im neuen jahr wird das gymnasium
offiziell den namen des holocaust
überlebenden max mannheimer tragen
dem wollen die schüler gerecht werden
jetzt erst recht nicht nur einstellungen
und werte werden stark vom elternhaus
geprägt das zuhause ist natürlich
genauso ausschlaggebend für die frage
wie kinder lernen welche bildungschancen
sie haben
schule kann nicht alles leisten nicht
alles korrigieren und nicht alles
kompensieren aber sie kann einiges wenn
die rahmenbedingungen stimmen
frankreich hat hier eine interessante
schuld politische entscheidung getroffen
in sogenannten problembezirken werden
die klassengrößen radikal reduziert
zumindest in den ersten schuljahren
thomas walde berichtet 5 4 3 2 1 0
bravo kinder gut gemacht in der klasse
von severin buhl geht es an diesem
vormittag um zahlen und eine zahl ist in
dieser ersten schulklasse besonders
wichtig und das ist die 12 so viele
schulanfänger kommen hier nämlich im
maximal zusammen seit die regierung von
emanuel makro klassen in sozialen
brennpunkten halbiert hat ich lerne
schreiben lesen und ganz viel eine
kleine klasse ist besser
da ist weniger lärm für die lehrerin die
kinder beginnen nicht alle auf demselben
niveau es sind viele kleinigkeiten im
alltag die man ihnen mitgeben kann und
so kommt man schneller voran als in
einer herkömmlichen klasse kleinere
klasse das heißt hier mehr
aufmerksamkeit das geht bis zur richtig
sitzenden brille details die besonders
wichtig sind vor allem in dieser
nachbarschaft
wir sind in einem viertel wo die kinder
aus verhältnissen stammen die etwas
komplizierter sind mit schwierigen
hintergründen man merkt es an ihrem
verhalten und daran wie sie lernen
karti die favorisierten franzosen
nachbarschaften wie shopping machen
unterprivilegiert was schöner klingt als
34 prozent arbeitslosigkeit gewalt und
drogenhandel
die startchancen für die kleinsten waren
hier nur theoretisch so gut wie anderswo
im egalitären frankreich bis zur
schulreform
wir sehen lernerfolge vor allem einen
fortschritt beim lesen ein erfolg der
zeit aufmerksamkeit und anleitung
erfordert die französische regierung
verfolgt mit der reform mehr als ein
akademisches ziel wenn man vertrauen
schafft wenn die schüler merken dass sie
mitkommen wenn sie ehrgeiz entwickeln
dann arbeitet man automatisch auch an
einer form des sozialen zusammenhalts
mehr als 5000 lehrer hat das land neu
eingestellt aber das reicht nicht für
das ehrgeizige projekt die schulen
müssen umschichten auch hier in champery
es gibt nicht genug lehrer die schule
will mehr haben
in den höheren klassen sind dann nämlich
wieder zu viele schüler da müssen sie
ohne die nötigen mittel auskommen
die schulen hoffen dass die
anfangserfolge sich in späteren höheren
klassen auswirken und die kinder in
frankreich problemvierteln damit nicht
nur für die schule sondern etwas für ihr
leben gelernt haben
der fahrdienst von u bahn wird in seiner
bisherigen form in deutschland verboten
damit verbundener weiter ja das deutsche
wettbewerbsrecht macht es dem taxi
konkurrenten aus den usa schwer hier in
deutschland seine app anzubieten immer
wieder stoppen
deutsche gerichte einzelne angebote
valerie haller sowie heute das
landgericht frankfurt kann man über in
deutschland eigentlich noch nutzen ja im
moment kann man aber offenbar noch
nutzen aber vermutlich nicht mehr lange
denn nach dem urteil des landgerichts
frankfurt darf der fahrdienst mit seiner
app ab sofort keine fahrten mehr
vermitteln zumindest nicht so wie bisher
über müsste sich nun nämlich einen
mietwagen konzession besorgen aber das
könnte dauern
in sieben großstädten gibt es aber schon
und wird auch viel genutzt für app geben
kunden ihren abhol ort und die ziel ein
wenig später werden fahrer und preis
angezeigt das landgericht frankfurt hält
das geschäftsmodell für
wettbewerbswidrig huber sei keine reine
plattform die nur fahrten mit mietwagen
vermittelt sondern aktiver fahrdienst
unternehmer zum einen fehlt über eine
eigene mietwagen konzession die
benötigte aber weil es im rechtsverkehr
gegenüber seinen kunden selbst als
unternehmer auftritt aber bestimmt
nämlich den preis und über sucht auch
für die einzelnen fahrten den fahrer
selber aus geklagt hatte die taxibranche
dass sie wütend es auf kuba ist
nachvollziehbar taxis haben ein monopol
mit vielen vorgaben ihre preise legen
die kommunen fest und bei über
entscheidet angebot und nachfrage damit
ist der fahrdienst oft günstiger als das
reguläre taxi das us unternehmen wird
jetzt schnell nachbessern müssen wenn es
weiter tätig sein will oder kann in
berufung gehen das verbot aber bleibt so
lange bestehen
vielen dank valerie für diese
erläuterungen in berlin ist am abend der
opfer des terroranschlags auf den
weihnachtsmarkt am breitscheidplatz
heute vor drei jahren gedacht worden
und 20 uhr zwei dem zeitpunkt des
anschlags läuteten die glocken der
gedächtniskirche zwölfmal in erinnerung
an die zwölf todesopfer anteilnahme
durch gedanken und gebete blumen und
kerzen 2016 hatte der islamistische
attentäter einen lastwagen in die
besuchermenge des weihnachtsmarktes
gesteuert eine meldung vom wintersport
zum auftakt des biathlon weltcups im
französischen le grand bornand hat
benedikt doll dem deutschen team einen
ersten sieg beschert große freude nach
einem durchwachsenen saisonstart
benedikt doll blieb ohne fehlschuss und
setzte sich im 10 kilometer sprint mit
94 sekunden vorsprung vor dem norweger
tarjei bö durch das unicef foto des
jahres zeigt den harten kampf ums
überleben von kindern in philippinischen
slums für das katholische hilfswerk
missio machte der deutsche fotograf
hartmut schwarzbach dieses bild von
ruini maria damals 13 jahre alt unter
dem titel die kinder der müll und der
tod zeigt er die ausweglose armut von
slum kindern deren tragödie sei nicht
vereinbar mit christlichen werten das
was von uns weiter geht es mit markus
lanz und den menschen 2009 10 der zdf
und direkt danach gibt es hier wieder
nachrichten und 0.30 ihn heute plus mit
hanna zimmermann und wir melden uns
morgen wieder an gegen 21.15 in der
halbzeitpause hoffenheim gegen die
borussia ist dahin auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter weltweit
betrachtet war der november 2009 10 zu
warm und landet sogar auf den zweiten
platz
und so wie es aussieht könnte das jahr
2019 ebenfalls auf den zweiten platz
landen also das zweitwärmste jahr seit
1880 werden
und das hat auswirkungen weltweit zum
beispiel auf extremwetterereignisse wie
in australien derzeit ist es zu trocken
zu heiß und das führt zu buschbränden
bei uns wird es allmählich nasa von
westen her kommt regen auf dieses
regenband das erreicht uns etwa morgen
bis zum mittag in der mitte deutschlands
und in der nacht da verdichtet sich die
bewölkung schon von westen her sonst
bildet sich nebel bei temperaturen von
minus 2 grad im südosten und 10 grad
ganz im westen
morgen wird es also nasa von westen her
und dazu gibt es sturmböen aus süd in
den östlichen landesteilen sieht es
freundlicher aus auch im südosten mit
temperaturen bis 18 grad mit föhn
unterstützung sieben grad sind es an der
ostsee ja und die nächsten tage am
samstag gibt es noch regen im osten
deutschlands sonst wird es allmählich
ruhiger mit werten zwischen 5 und 10
grad am sonntag wird es deutlich
durchwachsener vier bis zehn grad und
montag gibt es sogar schneeflocken in
den mittelgebirgen damit wünsche ich
ihnen einen schönen abend